oxen seatbelt
ari is talking about wee
but she has no clue what she's about to
see
so you didn't think to tell me that you
would be training with a girl ari goes
off on binyam and his training partner
at the gym
because bingham didn't tell her he would
be training
with a woman you didn't hey you didn't
what's your name
and guess what melissa with the
mouthpiece what's your name
didn't stay quiet you look great
as i should hey yeah it's not like this
that's what i do he's very talented he's
about to be a star like why are you
interrupting his training sessions yep
it got messy y'all it reminded me of
when you're a kid and you're somewhere
you're not supposed to be and your
parent comes in makes a scene and
snatches you out of there
this is so
embarrassing
let's talk about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissa before
we get into ari and benny i have to show
you some quick must-see moments one kobe
tells emily to she shut the [__] up
in front of her mom
the disrespect
this comes after she keeps trying to
tell him how to clean up the horse
manure
while he wants to be left alone i don't
even need your help
your ring's so rude
i'm being rude
can you just shut the [__] up
kobe kobe kobe
this sweet guy is turning a little salty
as the culture clashes between these two
are starting to get real
and it's so damn cold i left africa it's
warm
ah
it means everything about cameron kobe
is missing cameroon and he's having a
hard time living with an american woman
who does not hold her tongue
she is just trying to make her family
know that she is in control of me he and
emily both keep talking about how their
relationship wasn't like this in china
making me like
second guess myself i think
i've never seen that kobe before but we
have to remember that they were only
there together for two months so
they didn't really know each other
all right second you all have to see
this fight between jabri and his friend
slash bandmate david
let me give you the backstory really
quick jabria miona are in chicago so
jabrie can record a song with his band
david who he has been friends with since
he was a child
isn't fond of miona because he thinks
she's distracting jabri he's one of the
most talented people i've ever met when
he's motivated and he has a goal you
can't stop jabri that's why i'm so
confused where how he doesn't see this
because that fire just deteriorated that
fire is just
gone miona she holds them back
once they get into the studio and it's
time to record
jabrie says he needs to text miona
really quick and i don't know if that
makes david jealous annoyed or what but
they go at it i want to focus i just
want to make sure that you know she's
not
like disturbing us you know like for not
you know she's okay like she got
everything she needs you know yeah hey
bro stop hey
[__]
look at spaceman trying to break it up
that's one small step for man we'll see
the aftermath of that next week but
right now
we have to talk about ari's outburst at
the gym
binyam has been skating on thin ice with
ari since he's been in the u.s
she's feeling a ton of pressure having
to carry the financial weight in this
relationship and honestly the emotional
weight too
in the beginning in the relationship
with benny i really appreciated that he
trusted me to handle the finances but
not at this point it's just like a big
stress on my mind
binyam can't work because of his
immigration status but they still need
to find a way to pay for this
two-bedroom apartment and life in the
u.s
so it frustrates ari that while she's
trying to manage their reality
what's happening in front of them
i want to be like super fighter like
maybe successful i'm dreaming
binium's just cruising and dreaming away
and because he's always dreaming it
leads me to have to always be the
practical one and like it doesn't leave
a lot of room for me to dream sometimes
because i'm too busy bringing him down
to earth i have to carry this whole
family oh
that must feel suffocating
look i'm all for dreaming i think
dreaming is important but you have to
tie up the loose ends that are in front
of you first so your dream can actually
manifest and once it does you can keep
it i want to be like an ufc fighter like
maybe championships that's why i'm
dreaming is that why you're here
last week bingham had dinner with ari's
family where he revealed his goals in
the u.s
and his plan if he and ari don't work
out i came for an ari both of my
families they tell me even ari if she
don't want you
she can sign for you for a green card
because it's good for me
but even after how easy he just let that
roll off his tongue
sometimes i worry
that i love benny more than he loves me
ari is doing what it takes to help make
binyam's mma dreams come true he wants
to entertain america
this ride or die of a fiancee who
clearly loves and believes in her man
finds benyam a gym where he can train
excitement brother how are you how are
you
all right all right yeah i've heard good
things about you i know vinnie is super
excited to be here and it's not just any
gym
she searched and made sure she found the
best one for mma fighting
it's the going above and beyond when
you're getting nothing in return
that does it for me one two
three one two one two
according to the mma coach binyam is
impressive
he has a great fundamental and
foundation
and i'm very excited to work with benny
he's gonna be prepared to walk in that
cage and be victorious but to get to the
next level the coach says that benny
needs to train for two hours every day
mind you this gym is 45 minutes away
from their house
so while bingham is eager and ready to
get started ari is taken back by this
info
because she's gonna be the one driving
him 90 minutes back and forth plus the
90 days
the whole point of the show is for them
to work on their relationship
not chase dreams separately but i'm
afraid that vinnie is prioritizing his
dreams over his family then it could
prevent us from getting married
that's good
now let me ask my fiance to see if she's
okay with it
none of that
i see why ari is about to go off on him
and that woman what's your name
speaking of that let's go ahead and get
into the day of the
altercation it's going down
it's a week later and benny's been
training at the gym every day and they
actually set up an amateur fight for him
which aria admits it's not great for
their relationship because now all the
focus is on mma who saw that coming
bingham tells her he knows this is a
sacrifice but he has plans to make money
from it but our girl ari did some
research and apparently it's not the
most lucrative career
who would have guessed
most mma fighters really don't make that
much money and a lot of the money that
they make goes right back into their
training again honey i can work and then
you could watch avi that would be very
helpful
well yeah of course
but i have to finish my training
don't be stressed again
yeah that's easy for him to say the
pressure isn't on him
some parents don't even sacrifice this
much for their child especially when
what they want is not a necessity in the
moment
i love you
ari drops binyam off at the gym
and once he enters the female fighter
melissa is there
and i was looking super close at their
interaction sorry i'm let's okay it's
all right good to have you here
took you long enough but you're here
yeah i'm sorry sorry just i'm driving
just long way just sounds like this it's
like that sometimes yeah all right get
warmed up we'll start working okay good
it's limitable
um what y'all think about benjamin
melissa
can i be messy for a moment can i be
messy i'm just playing i'm not gonna be
messy yet because honestly
i didn't get to just said anything was
going on between them they just seemed
cool but they might have trained
together before let's go to the park
meanwhile ari takes avi to the park and
oh yeah she officially has a job
congrats sorry
i'm feeling really overextended lately
on top of driving vinnie to mma practice
i just got a remote job at my friend's
social media company so like between
being in the car taking care of avi and
working on my phone it's just like just
too much okay oh okay
i have the email written and everything
but i just needed to like copy and paste
all the emails or whatever yeah i am i'm
actually at the playground with avi um
this is not how i pictured our time in
the us would be like it feels like
benny's doing his own thing while i'm
over here taking care of everything else
forget that's what it feels like
that's what's happening want to see
daddy let's go to daddy
you miss daddy
when ari makes it back to the gym to
pick up benny she seems to be in a good
mood
excited to see him
[Music]
but what she walks into
makes her stomach drop and if you know
the feeling
you know the feeling
skirt u-turn
look at abby's face he was confused too
can you just watch avi for a minute
she said let me put my baby away because
mommy is about to go off
so you didn't think to tell me that you
would be training with a girl
oh the green eyed monster is coming out
hey you didn't what's your name no one's
though look you just talked to me no i'm
talking to her what's your name
melissa so you have full makeup i'm
usually when you get out of my way ari
is probably thinking you're not here to
work you're here to look cute for my man
see bingham this is why it's important
to make sure your home life is together
before you start putting energy
somewhere else because as we can see
here it can mess up opportunities now
melissa is having to deal with you and
ari's problems
you didn't think that you would tell me
what she had a competition have
competition just right but you didn't
think you should tell your future wife
that you're training with the girl
that's fine to just subscribe to this
live stream did you think that you
should tell your wife the truth that
there's a girl here named melissa
because sorry i just i forgot just you
forgot you forgot there's no one else
here
how could you forget there's not so many
people
for a relationship that already has
trust issues
to walk in and see your partner rolling
on the ground with another woman like
this
is a lot to take in
that fire bubbling up in your chest
unfortunately sometimes it just carries
you away
jealousy is a natural human emotion and
in a perfect world we would all know how
to handle it and use it for our
development but it's not a personal
world so is a reaction like ari's okay
no
but is it understandable
yes
and let's be real there are some people
who would have done worse
oh my god you if you have a boyfriend
right you do you tell him the people
that you train with um i don't have a
boyfriend but let me tell you something
this game you gotta go with who you
gotta go with right but yeah you still
wear fake eyelashes to the gym
she keeps bringing up her makeup which
ari she probably did it for the tv
cameras and not your man
but
i digress
so anyway after ari calls melissa out
for wearing lashes at the gym
she gives her a compliment you look
great ari says i'm not a hater but
don't touch my man
you look great but that compliment
doesn't stop things from getting spicy
you look great
as i should hey it's not like this
i don't like this type of energy in the
gym
i understand you're something you guys
need
i'm ready to go
ah the insecurities gotta go women are
training with men all the time equal
rights equal fights like he's very
talented he's about to be a star like
why are you interrupting his training
sessions like do you want him to fail
she might be right about women and men
training together i don't know much
about mma but i'm not gonna lie when she
said this he's very talented he's about
to be a star like why are you
interrupting his training sessions like
do you want him to fail the petty side
of me said oh hold on girl stay in your
place no one asks you about his talent
and does ari want him to fail
she's the reason why he's even in this
gym
you're being dishonest you should have
told me who you're practicing with says
she asking me yes i have a girl they
have a boy like that that's what i tell
them if she asks him he's the names i
don't know he doesn't say girl boy he
doesn't say anything no details if
you're not going to be honest about what
you're doing and if you're not going to
be honest about you know uh who's here
and if you're not going to be specific
with details and then
no problem this we we walk in like them
when you go back into anything
just waiting to talk no no no no let me
answer i think i'm done no no no no no
let me answer that
next time no son let me tell you just
like something oh benjamin watch your
hand no i'm okay tell y'all just make
something
nightmare
so what do you think did ari overreact
was bingham wrong for not giving her
every detail about who was at the gym
which as i say that sounds a bit extreme
hey what's your name no one's though
look you just talked to me no i'm
talking to her what's your name in my
opinion i don't think it was the best
move for ari to go after melissa the way
she did when binyam was the one she
truly had the problem with
but the truth is sometimes when you're
jealous
you don't think straight i'm very
emotional plus i think this outburst was
also a result of ari's frustration with
binyum boiling over she stressed about
finances which
is never fun
she can see that binyam is clearly more
interested in building his mma career
than building a life with her
ouch
truth hurts and on top of all of that
she did all the work to get him in this
gym
and she has to walk in the door and see
this
so you didn't think to tell me that you
would be training with a girl
tell me what would you have done
that's a lot of emotions to deal with at
once
but you know they say life is about
choices and right now ari has about 70
days to decide if she's okay with having
someone like binyum as a husband
i'm not saying he's a horrible person
because we know that's not the case
but based off their track record i
wouldn't be surprised if there continues
to be a tendency for his needs and
dreams to come before aries
i don't know if that has anything to do
with the fact that his nickname has been
baby for all of these years or what but
from the outside looking in
it's not fair and because he's always
dreaming it leads me to have to always
be the practical one and like it doesn't
leave a lot of room for me to dream
sometimes now minor spoiler alert when i
spoke to binyam and ari last month she
said that relationship has actually
gotten better
i see a change in the relationship
i'm getting better about things and
i think video is getting better so
hopefully that includes their dynamic
being more of a give and take situation
instead of ari just giving giving giving
in bingham taking taking taking
all right next week kobe is nervous as
emily's dad sits him down to figure out
his plan in america have a seat
emily's god is a little intimidating so
i'm a little nervous
what is your plan it's got a lot of
mouths to feed and uh i'm not paying for
it period her dad said period i know
that's right dad
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t because we are covering
it all i will see you next time